un an que les Pyrénées-Orientales n'ont
pas eu de véritables pluies Denis
producteur d'abricots doit se résoudre à
l'impensable jeté sa production pour
pouvoir peut-être sauver ses arbres
c'est vraiment la solution finale c'est
des arbres qui ont qui ont déjà passé
les premiers mois sans une goutte d'eau
on va essayer de travailler au moins à
la survie déjà en alerte sécheresse
renforcée le département passera
officiellement en état de crise le 10
mai prochain une situation inédite
conséquence du dérèglement climatique
c'est tout un symbole dans le
Puy-de-Dôme la préfecture est élargi les
mesures de restriction d'eau à 31
communes de plus dont celle de Volvic ou
son produit les célèbres bouteilles
d'eau minérale la ville avait certes
déjà été placée en alerte sécheresse en
2022 mais c'est la première fois qu'elle
l'est aussitôt dans l'année les beaux
jours sont de retour à Bapaume mais
malheureusement les moustiques aussi à
ce moment qu'il devient c'est ce mec
vous entendez c'est le retour des
moustiques écoutez
[Musique]
devant cette église andalouse ou les
températures dépassent déjà les 30
degrés les fidèles s'en remettent à Dieu
pour faire tomber la pluie
je suis venu ici pour voir le Seigneur
et je suis convaincu qu'il va nous
donner de l'eau
une telle procession n'avait plus eu
lieu ici depuis 1949 depuis quelques
semaines l'Espagne fait face à un
épisode de sécheresse historique ayez
tous s'il vous plaît à partir maintenant
l'esprit mal placé nous allons garder
nous sommes ensemble c'est difficile la
voici ce que vous voyez ce que je vois
oui voilà tout le monde voit ce que je
vois c'est nickel ça a été pris un
oignon
de Terre-Neuve vous savez cet immense
île canadienne qui voit en ce moment
c'est le printemps défilé des cohortes
d'iceberg c'est la saison en moyenne 800
par an mais ça varie beaucoup il paraît
que c'est une bonne année et merci
d'être là en tout cas tu es à côté de
Jean-Michel maire tu es contente ouais
tu es célibataire
tu es marié fiancé
[Rires]
le photographe est originaire de la
ville de dildo ça veut dire godmichet
voilà il y en a qui le savent pas et que
ça paye en bouche
et en plus de ça cette ce blog de glace
ultra viril dérive dans la baie de
conception
oui tout est vrai je vous l'avais dit et
donc de là que proviennent les bébés
iceberg là ça se présente aujourd'hui
[Musique]
oh là là franchement faut qu'il arrête
de lire le tractopelle
c'est bon là les deux pièges du mariage
le compte joint
et la carte bleue et on a des trucs nous
dans les divorces on a quand même des
mecs qui payent c'est les mecs hein
avant de faire ça venez voir votre
avocat j'en sais rien poser moi la
question on est moins tracé mais façon
l'argent liquide tu vas le retirer à la
banque donc il y a une trace on sait pas
que tu t'en es servi pour aller dans un
hôtel avec ta maîtresse quoi et alors
j'ai même un petit rituel le dimanche
soir pour partager avec tout le monde
parce que ça permet peut-être d'aborder
une bonne semaine c'est le bain relaxant
un peu de musique un bon livre et Madame
qui est en bas justement c'est d'être
tout seul à ce moment-là
c'est ça qui est vraiment relaxant
est-ce que en gros trompez votre femme
utiliser l'argent
merci Marianne
vous ne pourrez plus faire de rencontres
amoureuse en Russie via tinder à partir
du 30 juin prochain et c'est loin d'être
une décision facile pour le groupe
puisque tinder est extrêmement populaire
en Russie en 2022 environ 3,5 millions
d'utilisateurs l'ont installé ce qui en
fait et bien l'application la plus
téléchargée sur branler Play Store mais
voici sur le papier la raison officielle
de ce retrait nous nous engageons à
protéger les droits humains que devient
François Fillon et bien regardez
à partir du moment où j'ai quitté la vie
publique je veux le rappeler je veux
dire je suis une personne privée et je
mène ma carrière professionnelle comme
je l'entends si j'ai envie de vendre des
rillettes sur la place sur la Place
Rouge je voudrais des rillettes sur la
Place Rouge c'est quoi ça vendre
derrière
dans le cadre d'une commission d'enquête
sur les ingérences étrangères une phrase
qui a été très commentée sur les chaînes
info dans les matinales on a même eu
droit à la question Henriette
Jean-Philippe Tanguy on va parler
rillettes si j'ai envie de vendre des
rillettes sur la Place Rouge je vendrai
des rillettes sur la Place Rouge
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque
de tuer Vladimir Poutine c'est ce qui
affirme Moscou qui annonce avoir abattu
deux drones au-dessus du Kremlin l'année
dernière comme on le voit sur ces images
diffusées par les médias russes censés
montrer l'attaque Vladimir Poutine
n'était pas sur place l'Ukraine des vols
des myrski on démenti tout attaque et
accuse la Russie de mise en scène
ça veut dire que la prochaine fois ça va
être la
quoi en fait la prochaine étape c'est
quoi n'importe quoi
[Rires]
en plus ça marchera pas avec la rime je
pense vu que il y a des choses
j'en ai plein qui me dit
moi aussi après quasiment 2 ans d'une
piètre collaboration mais si le PSG
c'est presque terminé selon nos
confrères des RMC Sport le
Paris-Saint-Germain a décidé hier de
suspendre son numéro 30 pour deux
semaines avec effet immédiat après la
nouvelle défaite millions à domicile
face à l'Orient dimanche Lionel Messi
s'est envolé en Arabie Saoudite pour
honorer un contrat personnel avec
l'Office du Tourisme saoudien sans
l'accord du PSG lundi il a donc manqué
un entraînement volontairement en gros
pour résumer ici au PSG ça a été ça a
été une catastrophe du début jusqu'à la
fin en terme d'image c'est c'est
horrible et de finir comme ça c'est
c'est encore pire avec lui le PSG n'aura
fait que rêver et maintenant ça se
termine en cauchemar Lionel Messi au PSG
résonnera finalement comme la fausse
bonne idée de l'air qatari
c'est quand exactement fin de l'affaire
c'est à quel moment de la journée
en fait on peut pas me demander
quelques jours avant de me trouver un
concept en fait c'est c'est comme
l'autre banc en fait c'est arrivé quand
j'étais quand j'étais dans mon bain
voilà c'est arrivé et voilà j'ai
beaucoup de temps
[Rires]
sur ces belles paroles moi je vous dis
bonne nuit